bonjour nous a remerciés
merci beaucoup d'être en direct avec
nous sur arte france pour faire un point
sur ce mouvement que vous avez entamé
mardi il y avait déjà eu un précédent si
je me souviens bien le 21 octobre
dernier peu médiatisé mais pourtant très
important il ya des problèmes également
dans dans l'établissement français du
sang
oui effectivement mais le mouvement est
en fête a commencé le 5 novembre 2020 et
a perduré tout l'année 2000 21 cas
aujourd'hui hélas pour quelle raison est
ce que vous mobiliser à nouveau
alors aujourd'hui et depuis le 5
novembre dernier on demande que le ségur
de la santé s'applique à l'ensemble des
salariés de l'établissement rentrer du
sang parce que vous n'étiez absolument
pas concernée finalement ou alors pris
en compte lors de ce ces cures de la
santé c'est bien ça
non c'est qu'ils étaient tout à fait
incroyable puisque en juillet en
septembre dernier l'accord sur le ségur
de la trentaine a été signé pour plus
d'un million d'agents hospitaliers et
l'établissement français du sang qui est
un établissement public de l'état une
api d'établissements de santé et
d'intérêt vital les personnels des
établissements n'ont pas été intégrés et
donc des écarts de salaires importants
sont à observer aujourd'hui avec la
fonction publique hospitalière qui crée
des problèmes d'attractivité des métiers
de 7 ça veut dire qu'il y à il ya d une
hémorragie pardon pour ce solo et jeux
de mots mais du personnel et du
personnel de l'établissement français du
sang qui s'en vont vers les hôpitaux
bah ils tendront vers les hôpitaux ou
vers d'autres structures puisque le
privé c'est aussi les hôpitaux privés
sont aussi alignés sur les salaires de
la fonction publique hospitalière donc
effectivement aujourd'hui on a on a
beaucoup de personnel qui quittent
l'établissement ou qui n'y restent pas
notamment ou deux par les mauvaises
conditions de travail que nous observons
aujourd'hui et donc la vacance de poste
et explose et du coup ce que vous
dénoncez vos conditions de travail
quelle conséquence elles ont très
concrètement sur la collecte de sang
à la conséquence c'est que tous les mois
ce sont des centaines de collectes
mobiles qui sont annulés voilà et on a
aussi des sites fixes ils ferment
régulièrement la veille pour le
lendemain faute de personnel alors alors
qu'il y à des donneurs
alors que les donneurs sont souvent là
oui effectivement alors qu'est ce que
vous demandez concrètement aujourd'hui
la le mouvement va durer jusqu'à demain
c'est ça
le mouvement et dure jusqu'à samedi
matin 8 heures d'accord et qu'est ce que
vous demandez qu'est ce que vous espérez
est ce que vous allez être reçu par par
les autorités
alors durant l'année 2021 on a été reçu
deux fois par un conseiller de ministre
de chargé de la santé mais ce sont ce
sont soit des téléréunions ou de dire et
de de courtoisie à aucun moment donné on
nous a vraiment vraiment écouter donc
bon
cet été une partie des personnels de
l'établissement donc les infirmiers les
techniciens de laboratoire et les cadres
médicaux techniques ont été revalorisées
à la hauteur du ségur mais uniquement
les personnels qui sont en poste qui ne
répond pas du tout à la problématique de
l'attractivité de l'établissement pour
les nouveaux personnels quelles
pourraient être les conséquences si
cette situation perdure pour l'ensemble
du secteur de la santé
c'est un peu découragé les donneurs
parce que le donneur et c'est quelqu'un
qui est bénévole qui vient donner de son
temps de son corps etc et
quand il vient et que des cohortes sont
fermées ou que la toilette t mobile pour
laquelle ils avaient prévu d'aller ne se
fait pas ben c'est vrai que c'est un peu
démotivant merci à vous benoît lemercier
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin je le rappelle vous êtes délégué
syndical central cfdt pour
l'établissement français du sang